let's go to our next caller from the 845
area code caller from 8:45 who's this go
ahead hey it's just James from Florida
8:45 in New York area code but I moved
down here all right well with peace and
love all area codes are welcome my
question is about the midterms in 2018
you know the people say that there's a
big blue wave coming I'm a little
skeptical because I know Democrats with
a million ways to mess things up you
know what I mean oh yeah but my question
is particularly about Maryland I was
looking at the governor's race down
there
and I found that the Republican
incumbent has like a 15-point lead in
the polls over the Democrat yeah and
Maryland is the traditionally blue state
and I'm wondering what uh what do you
think about that you know I haven't been
following that super closely is that
where Ben Jealous
is running against Ben Jealous as the
Democrat yeah Ben Jealous and the
Republican Larry Hogan yeah it's not
good if that's accurate I haven't seen
polling recently but assuming that
you're right that would be a very
different that would that's hurt that
those would be numbers that paint a very
different story than the overwhelming
blue wave story here's the thing I don't
know enough about that particular race
to say too much of value about it every
single election needs to be thought of
as winnable but an uphill battle right
there so that there's no excuse to stay
home because you think it's an easy
Republican win and there's no excuse to
stay home because you think it's an easy
Democratic win just period if there's an
opportunity to vote no matter what you
think the results might be pretend that
your vote could make a difference
because it could and go out and vote
right period I think that that's the
approach and I also have some fear of
the blue wave talking points that it
sounds like you're skeptical about it I
also am and that's why what I'm saying
is I don't care where you're voting
think of every race as a tossa mm-hmm
definitely yeah I mean I see these polls
everywhere like I see in Massachusetts
Charlie Baker has Leigh
last poll was a couple months ago but he
had like a 30 point lead in the polls
yeah not surprising that that I don't
even consult that that's not going to be
a factor in the I mean in Massachusetts
we get these kind of like decaf
Republicans as governor's often it's
happened with a you know bill weld and
Mitt Romney and there have been others
wrong yeah and they often kind of go
under the radar because they're not
ideologically bonkers Republicans as a
general thing and they end up getting
reelected on the basis of their sort of
like administer job they're doing
administrative Lee so I wouldn't read
too much into that yeah I mean on the
one hand I do kind of think there's a
blue wave happen because I do think
there's a lot of energy on the
Democratic side like currency last night
Vermont gem there was a transgender got
a got put on the ballot yep and like I
mean I'm skeptical about yeah you know I
just know Democrats know how to screw
things up everyone said Hillary oh she's
a shoo-in yeah yeah you know this
optimism cautious optimism is the word I
appreciate the appreciate the call
everybody vote in every single election